hi my name is Bryce and I'm a product
manager and also the siege security
officer for Google cloud and this is an
overview of how assured workloads can
help you run sieges compliant workloads
on Google cloud ready let's get started
[Music]
Regulatory Compliance can be a challenge
for governments and businesses looking
to use the cloud many workloads have
strict compliance requirements
surrounding data residency data access
and personal access
at the same time you don't want
compliance challenges to prevent you
from using the latest most Innovative
cloud services
one area where compliance can be a
challenge is when you're running
workloads at store and process criminal
justice and law enforcement information
the criminal justice Information
Services Division of the United States
Federal Bureau of Investigations sets
standards for information security
guidelines and agreements for protecting
criminal justice information or cji
Google Cloud can support municipalities
law enforcement agencies and other
organizations looking to run sieges
compliant workloads on the cloud Google
Cloud meets all the nist requirements
outlined by the FBI to support criminal
justice information
so how do you start the process of
bringing sieges workloads to Google
Cloud this is broken down into three key
steps one executing the siege of
security policy with Google
two fingerprint background checking
Google support staff and finally using
assured workloads to set up your
regulated boundary on Google Cloud
the first step is executing the siege
security policy
the siege of security policy is a set of
requirements created by the FBI
describing the appropriate controls to
protect the sources transmission storage
and access to criminal justice
information when Google works with a
customer requiring siege's compliance we
are able to execute the sieges security
policy as a contract between the
customer and Google or the state's Siege
security officer on behalf of the entire
State this also includes supporting
audits of our physical and Technical
controls to help customers understand
how their cji is protected the second
step is adjudicated personnel
Google works with each customer or state
to execute FBI fingerprint background
checks to meet the sieges security
policy we are able to provide either
digital or physical fingerprint cards to
complete this process this means that
only successfully FBI fingerprint
background checked Google Personnel
located in the United States that you
approve can provide support for your
sieges workloads the final step is
onboarding to assured workloads as we
discussed in an earlier video assured
workloads is a tool that helps you run
secure and compliant workloads on Google
Cloud it configures and enforces
platform controls to create regulated
boundaries on public Cloud
infrastructure
all organizations have to do is choose a
regulatory framework and Google Cloud
will put the necessary Cloud controls in
place to help make sure your compliance
requirements are met in this case
customers who require sieges compliance
just need to select see just when
creating an assured workloads folder and
Google will restrict cji to remain in
the US using data residency controls for
in-use at rest and in transit restrict
cji access to only those googlers that
you have approved to support your
workloads restrict your developers to
using only sieges compliant products and
services and configure your folder to
use customer managed encryption keys
this is all done in just a few clicks
and you're ready to go when you use
assured workloads you set controls
selectively on a workload by workload
basis you get access to the same Google
Cloud products and services ensuring
compatibility between your regulated and
Commercial Cloud environments on Google
Cloud
this is key to providing customers with
the ability to support multiple types of
compliance all within a single Google
Cloud organization with assured
workloads Google Cloud takes a different
approach from other Cloud providers who
operate separate government clouds for
regulated workloads
government clouds are run through
specialized stand-alone data centers
which can impact the government's access
to the latest most Innovative
Technologies but with Google Cloud's
assured workloads there is no separate
Cloud you can run sieges compliant
workloads while still benefiting from
the latest cloud services like bigquery
dataflow and Google kubernetes engine
in fact all the following Google cloud
services are in scope for sieges
additionally it's easy to get started
with assured workloads organizations
just need to navigate to the compliance
section of the Google Cloud console
where you can manage the requirements
for your regulated workloads with just a
few clicks this is in contrast to the
Legacy govcloud approach where customers
start out with more of a bare bones
environment to build it and finally
while gov Cloud pricing can be
unpredictable assured workloads pricing
is based on a fixed fee subscription and
a consistent 20 uplift for resources
to get started with assured workloads
for sieges please contact your State's
Google Cloud sales team through our
contact form Linked In the video's
description
the process will be determined by
whether or not Google sieges policy has
already been approved in your state if
it is you can move directly to using
assured workloads to secure your sieges
data on Google Cloud if Google sieges
policy has not yet been approved for
your state you will need to go through a
state see just approval process but
customers don't have to do this alone
because of our shared fade approach
we'll partner with all of our customers
to take on more responsibility and we
will be with you every step of the way
through this process
so there you have it an overview of how
Google Cloud can Support sieges
Compliance in all U.S states using
assured workloads if you're interested
in learning more please check out
cloud.google.com contact to get in touch
with your State's Google Cloud platform
sales team or click on the form Linked
In the description and remember that
assured workloads is priced on regulated
resource consumption only giving
customers greater flexibility and
control of their costs and make sure to
check out the other videos in our Series
where we talk about assured workloads in
the United States assured workloads in
Europe and how to build with compliance
in mind thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you